son commandant peut-être que j'ai tort
on n'est pas bien là on est très très
bien à la ferai ce cadre on invite
recevoir est faible
déjà j'adore ton non merci quel
imaginaire tu mets derrière ce nom est
faible qui est évidemment un pseudo
puisque tu t'appelles axel en effet
c'est pas moi qui ai trouvé ce nom l'a
trouvée pour moi et j'espère que enfin
je prends c'est un peu comme une
flatterie je sais pas si c'est mon
excellent y prend
est ce que j'aime bien justement c'est
qu'il éveille beaucoup d'imaginaire ce
nom sur la jeunesse sur d'érotisme aussi
et sur tout un tas de choses qu un
éphèbe c'était un jeune grec qui partent
au service militaire et moi ça me parle
pour tout un tas de raisons
et j'aime bien aussi laissé un petit peu
les gens s'approprier ce nom et
construire quelque chose là-dessus
commande je m'en vais perdre le nord
axel il a 26 ans mais et fab a quel âge
est faible il a trois ans quatre ans à
peu près voilà ça fait pas mal de temps
que je fais des concerts en france j'en
ai fait je suis un petit peu aux états
unis et que je tourne que je rencontre
du monde et là je sens bientôt mon
premier disque ça fait déjà trois ans
que j'existe merci et dans quoi est ce
que tu a puisé la force de te lancer
solo parce que tu as été aussi musicien
dans d'autres formations
ouais j'ai beaucoup aimé jouer en groupe
il ya tout un tas de choses que ça
permet l'écriture à plusieurs le travail
à plusieurs mais j'avais besoin de faire
des chansons dans lesquelles je me
mettais vraiment à 100% que ce soit sur
les textes sur la composition et j'aime
beaucoup créé tout seul et en fait ça
s'est fait un petit peu naturellement je
suis rendu compte qu'il y avait un
morceau que je pouvais pas adapté en
groupe et que j'avais besoin de créer
mon personnage mon identité et je les
fais un petit peu parce que j'avais
besoin de le faire
tu as une petite fascination pour les
eighties en termes de sonorités thème
bien tout ce qui est sainte et c est ce
que tu as des artistes de variété de
chanteurs des années 80 qui t'ont marqué
vite influence encore ouais carrément
j'adore etienne daho et pas que pour sa
période années 80 d'ailleurs parce qu'il
a réussi à avoir une carrière qui a
évolué au fur à mesure des époques s'est
toujours adapté les fascinants et je
suis aussi très ferme de mylène farmer
et surtout de ses deux trois premiers
albums que je trouve incroyable et ce
que j'aime bien dans les années 80 c'est
qu'on n'avait pas peur d'en faire des
tonnes de foot de la couleur de
de faire des choses bizarres et ses
rangs une période je crois que dans
laquelle j'aurais été sans doute heureux
de créer des trucs et qu'est ce qui te
fait danser alors qu'est ce qui me fait
danser franchement je suis pas difficile
c'est vrai voilà comment la cie dans
l'herbe mais je sais pas tu vois je peux
danser sur un tweak frites tu vois et je
peux danser sur de la broustic noir
score sur du hip hop sur la trappe
je crois que tout peut me faire danser
en fait et dit de près tout aussi peu de
faire danser parce qu'on va quand même
le dire c'est la classe tu as fait la
première partie de 10,2 preto autant
machine to machine kembs à la tour ils
vont gentiment invité c'était hyper
chouette je sais pas s'il me fait danser
du depretto mais en tout cas il me parle
beaucoup et me paraît avec ses textes
avec ce qu'ils racontent avec ce qu'il
incarne et j'étais rentré très fier de
faire ses premières sorties c'est bien
toi tu es multi instrumentiste j'ai vu
que tu jouais même de l'accordéon merde
t'es un gars semblent sur l'a7 j'ai vu
ça sur sur les internets sérieux c'est
pas vrai
[Rires]
la musique tu l'a apprise mais comment
est-ce qu'on apprend à composer des
paroles et des dégradés texte alors pour
le coup j'ai jamais pris de cours pour
apprendre à composer avec ou à écrire
des textes et c'est quelque chose que
j'ai fait très naturellement après avoir
effectivement à jouer des instruments
donc l'accordéon quand j'avais 6 ans la
guitare ensuite plus en autodidacte le
piano est ce que j'ai appris par contre
c'est à produire de la musique sans
ordinateur on a tout un bagage technique
qui me permet d'aller chercher de
construire un morceau de celle d'aller
chercher des sonorités partant de la
composition le texte c'est quelque chose
qu'on va chercher un peu dans nos tripes
et puis au départ on construit un petit
peu comme on fait avec des lego des fois
ça tient pas trop la route et puis au
bout d'un moment on arrive à faire une
maison 40pb gueule mais je crois que
j'ai appris un peu tout seul
et aussi peut-être le monde de la nuit
le monde la fed
l'amour comme prof ou keep orages
[Musique]
j'occupe d'orage c'est un club que j'ai
tourné quand j'étais aux états unis j'ai
fait une petite tournée là-bas il ya une
somme de 3 ans un peu classe quand même
mais c'est bien le dire c'était vraiment
une petite tournée j'avais juste un sac
à dos mon ordinateur un petit clavier et
je faisais des clubs de toutes sortes et
j'ai fait quelques pas mal de clubs drag
queen et orages ça parle de ça en fait
c'est toute l'énergie que je trouvais
dans ce milieu-là des gamins pour
beaucoup en fait qu envie de s'emparer
de leur avenir déjà d'en découdre de
faire quelque chose avec le monde qui
nous a laissés qui n'est pas forcément
très bon état et dans lequel on a un peu
de mal à trouver notre place parfois
donc l'orage c'est ça et c'est vrai que
j'étais très très influencé par le monde
de la nuit le monde courir surtout au
début des sables un garçon qui est très
attaché à sa région
est ce qu'il ya des lieux culturels
qui ont marqué ton parcours et auquel tu
es encore très attachés aujourd'hui
oui bien sûr donc moi j'habite à tour
qui est une ville que j'adore et là
immédiatement je pense au château du
plessis qui est un lieu dans lequel je
suis en résidence depuis maintenant deux
ou trois ans qui est vraiment un lieu
formidable qu'il est ce une place à ces
artistes comme j'en ai plus vus ailleurs
on peut y répéter gratuitement et c'est
vraiment une équipe qui est hyper
disponibles je les adore et je les aime
et tour est une ville très riche
culturellement et la région science
aussi je crois et on s'ennuie jamais et
tout un tas de lieux super en tout cas
tu as été un digne représentant de la
région centre val de loire sur la scène
des inouïe au printemps de bourges en
2019 est ce qu'il ya eu un avant et un
après pourquoi est-ce que ça a servi de
tremplin aussi en terme de visibilité
j'ai eu beaucoup de retours très
positifs sur mon concert moi je vais
démissionner ça les gens qui sont venus
nous saluer et qui vont du canton tandis
que sortir on sera présents donc ces
tests est pour moi une fierté j'étais
vraiment très content et maintenant
j'espère que tout ça va se confirmer que
les disques qui va sortir
bah on sera là et ça fait plaisir
merci de m'avoir invité comment as tu en
sais pas fait mais j'ai quand même
encore une question comment tu le sens
là le défi comptes a lancé de mêlée ton
univers à celui des alisiers avec pour
thématique le retour la nature bah c'est
clair que c'était pas du tout un truc
que j'aurais imaginé faire clairement je
suis très content de faire un fils a
écrit filet ils ont été adorables on à
échanger autour d'un morceau qui
banquent jardin d'hiver d'henri salvador
qu un très joli morceau et ça s'est très
très bien passé
c'est très très cool franchement j'ai
hâte de jouer cc c'est un défi en fait
qu'on n'ait pas vraiment je crois qu'on
va le faire à la cool quand on aurait
joué dans le jardin mais c'est ça
renversant c'est la famille tu sais
exactement vous remercie beaucoup est
faible